das couscous das direkt aus marokko oder
das kannst du mit dem was wir hier ein
kuss kuss christus kannst du dich denn
vergleichen
ich war jetzt auch unter teilen vor
südafrika und costa rica
ich bin damals von einem einheimischen
überfall machen ganz authentisch
er hat mir ein messer in den
oberschenkel gerammt durch die schöne
marie alter keiner will deine teigigen
kag stelzen sehen oder langweiligen
hipster stories hören aber keine ahnung
ich sehe jetzt kommt
[Musik]
heute reisen kapitel 1 massentourismus
ich reise individuell japan oder den
gehalt und ich bin im urlaub doch an
land erleben und deswegen niemals
hotelzimmern uhr alvin b
da kann man mit den menschen den kontakt
und ja ich bin schon einfach spannend
vielleicht solltest du die menschen
einfach meine ruhe lassen
airbnb vermittelt weltweit mehr
übernachtungen als die fünf größten
hotelketten zusammen das ist keine
alternative zu massentourismus
das ist massentourismus airbnb macht
reisen billiger
dann kriegen noch mehr menschen übers
wochenende nach prag oder lissabon und
noch mehr wohnungen die wir frage oder
lissabonner gedacht waren werden
ferienwohnung weil es mehr geld bringt
ist ein problem aber ich vermiete meine
wohnung ja auch wenn ich selber nicht da
bin ja also ich gebe der community quasi
was zurück interessant trinkst du das
noch danke hier in berlin zum beispiel
brauche ich eine lizenz um bei airbnb zu
vermieten dann kann der kunde sehen ob
es nicht um ein legales angebot handelt
nicht wahr
letztes jahr hatten aber 90 prozent
aller berliner airbnb angebote keine
lizenznummer hast du ja in dem sinne
jetzt natürlich nicht aber was das ist
so typisch deutsch
dieser ganze bürokratie wahnsinn dass
wir uns doch der grund weswegen verreise
20 bis 30.000 wohnungen in berlin werden
somit nicht mehr an berliner sondern an
besoffene engländer oder schlecht
tätowierte spanier verbietet in palma de
mallorca sind die mietkosten in den
letzten fünf jahren um 50
unser reise wahnsinn ist nicht nur
schlecht fürs klima nein der ist auch
sozial ungerecht
ja gut aber wenn sie dann auch schon
nach mallorca spanier kapitel 2
ich flieg doch nicht ich verrate nur
wenn es unbedingt sein muss man nach
paris kommen schneller umzug 21
millionen deutsche flogen 2018 auf einen
anderen kontinent klar wer bitteschön
kontinent sein
die hälfte aller deutschen kann sich
vorstellen für die umwelt weniger zu
fliegen konkret weniger fliegen wollen
aber nur vier prozent in schweden gibt
es dafür ernsthaft neue worte flugs kam
flughafen anfliegen scheiße ist oder das
nie klüger heimliches fliegen will
einfach nicht dabei gesehen werden und
tags krieg zog stolz ich bin der geilste
wahrlich bahn fahre ich bin letztens von
berlin nach köln nicht geflogen
ich habe das für dich getan und für alle
kinder fühlt sich geil an
und natürlich ist bahnfahren für besser
fürs klima aber auch ein viertel des
bahnstroms tten kommt immer noch aus
braun und steinkohle
jetzt aber mal ganz ehrlich was heißt
eigentlich in berlin gemacht
kumpel von mir hat neuen grill 16 flamme
ich bin dem bücherfest was das ding aus
dem stick macht ja osten total cross in
butterzart
ja was ein bisschen neben aller salz
drauf fertig ist die laube mal eben zum
grillen nach berlin fahren ist nicht
klimafreundlich auch nicht mit dem zug
und jetzt jetzt sage ich was was
wirklich keiner hören will gott ihr
werdet mich hassen
ein aus deutscher wutbürger bis ein
ganzes leben nicht aus dem doofen
erzgebirge rausgekommen ist da hrt wählt
und nicht fragen wie klimawandel und der
tut mir bis klima als wir große box
bleibt nämlich zu hause wir aber ist
dass dich zum kratzen ungarische punkt
da kapitel 3
ja nach sri lanka kommen sie eben nicht
im bus aber ich mache co2 kompensation
co2 kompensation boomt die organisation
atmosfair meldet 2018 40 prozent mehr
spenden 95 millionen euro
ja ich fliege aber voll geil ich
finanzieren wir zu klimaprojekte das
sind ja keine ahnung wann bin ich jesus
obwohl prinzip co2 kompensation also
eigentlich bin ich so was wie jesus aber
die idee ist super
mit dem geld werden windräder in indien
oder biogasanlagen in ghana gebaut
5000 dieser projekte wurden in einer eu
studie untersucht leider sparen acht von
zehn projekten überhaupt kein co2 ein
und durch das gute gewissen haben reiche
leute wie wir das gefühl noch mehr
reisen zu können aber
ich will euch nicht den spaß verderben
schönen abend noch wisst ihr eigentlich
wie viel co2 dieses mexikanische
importiert sollte als aber raus bitte
raus sofort die wahrheit tut weh wird
ihr euch schlecht gut so
wisst ihr wie ihr euch noch viel
schlechter fühlt indem er die nächste
folge verpasst oder abonniert einfach
diesen kanal dann passiert das nicht
nein